[Music]
to
uh to express his views so that's how
we're going to run the meeting only
those
present here in the chamber will be able
to vote um
i hope that explains it all we'll get
strath started straight away with the
agenda the first item is apologies for
absence
and we have apologies from councillor
parking and councillor foster
are there any others that we need to
record
non-receive chair okay thank you alan
uh and then the next item is
declarations of interest are there any
that anyone wishes to report
again on the sieve chair okay
and then the minutes of the last meeting
held on the 20th of may
um i'm happy to move that we accept them
we have a second thank you seconded by
councillor powell
all those in favor okay that's carried
thank you very much
and then the next item then is the
council plan
uh performance update so i'll hand over
to cath drury
if you can just give us a quick uh
summary of the papercut thank you
okay yes i will do so as you can see
from the report
uh just over half the targets at q4
which ends end of march are on track
uh 21 have been achieved so far
at that point in time and 25 percent of
the targets have been affected by covid
obviously going forward at q1 we will be
expecting a big reduction in that figure
as the national restrictions have lifted
and obviously now our
leisure centers are open and we've
started
uh you know we've resumed such things as
environmental health enforcement work so
the council is
back operating under more normal
circumstances so that will be
reflected in the q1 report just a few
things to pick out on the report by
aim under the economy aim
just to note that eco 20 is shown as
overdue but we are expecting that to be
signed off at q1
so no concerns there under
environment uh we just to
confirm that number five failed
for 2021 as we've
reported a couple of times now obviously
we're expecting that to improve in the
next financial year there's additional
resources
that's gone into planning enforcement so
we expect that to pick up going forward
under residence um good to see that a
few have been achieved there with the
video remote interpreting solution
being live and the grants reaching its
target on the community action
grant front and then lastly under
services
as target number 18 is overdue that's
the council's petition scheme
and there's a recommendation to extend
that to december 21
and it's fully expected the world will
be done and dusted within that time
scale
and that concludes the report chair
okay thank you very much kath for that
um are there any comments from any
cabinet members
i think the only thing i would uh just
say is that when cabinet discussed this
paper i think in terms of the second
recommendation
although we appreciate there has been
some delay with that uh
with achieving that target and obviously
there is some some work on going i think
all of us felt a bit uncomfortable about
extending the
uh extending the time frame i think we'd
probably prefer to just leave it as
overdue
appreciating that it it is going to take
longer so if
if there's no i'm assuming there's no
problem with that in terms of the way
that we report it will just continue to
be
um labeled as overdue yeah that's
absolutely fine what we'll do is
we'll just pull through in the
commentary that the revised data will
work into but we'll leave the statuses
overdue so it's clear to
for reporting purposes yeah okay
if everyone's happy with that then i'll
move that we accept recommendation
one and leave it to that
thank you that's seconded by councillor
cupid all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
and then we come to the paper on
recommissioning the volunteering
community sector infrastructure support
to
groups in northeast derbyshire so i will
hand over to councillor powell to
to talk to this paper thank you chairman
um over and over a period of time there
have been some issues
um uh with um the
delivery of what we want in this context
and this is quite a small part of our
overall
budget for support that we give across
north east derbyshire but it
nevertheless is a significant one
and so what we are proposing is that
we effectively go out to tender i
suppose
and procure um
a system that is based on what outcomes
we want
rather than what people might be
prepared to give us
and we need it to be completely and
utterly aligned with the council plan
with all our aims and aspirations
uh and we also want to make sure that
it is monitored adequately um
so and i i will recommend it to you
um it isn't important piece of piece of
work that
we need to procure um and um i know
steve lee and chris burdette and the
team have worked very hard to try and
come up with
a solution that actually gives us what
we want
so um unless there are any questions
chair i will
um move that we accept the
recommendations containing item
in items one and two and that's to agree
to uh commissioning of the an external
organization to deliver
an outcomes-based approach to support
the community and voluntary sector in
northeast derbyshire
for an initial period of six months from
first of october
and to march and next year and
agree the flexibility to extend the
contract
subject to budget availability and a
regular
three monthly review um and assessment
to measure its impact
in that chair thank you uh thank you
council power
and council running are there any um
comments anyone wishes to make
in relation to this paper just to say
chair that's uh i think it really is
important to look at the impact
and this is quite significant sometimes
we give to voluntary organizations and
i think look at the impact make sure it
aligns with our
council's plan and our aspirations is
really key at this time
absolutely fully agree uh council
running thank you very much for that
um okay is there anything that steve or
tris wish to add just while you're on on
the call
not from my chair i think i think we've
covered everything uh thank you but
happy to answer any questions
okay thanks thanks steve in that case
i'll uh i'll move to the vote then so
all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
and then the next paper is the uh green
homes grant
update paper which is a part uh council
of powell paper and parts
uh councillor kenyon i think the first
part is more
uh it's a bit of both but it's probably
more powerful
invite councillor powell at first to
speak and then councillor kenyon if
that's
if that's okay
thank you chair um as you know
um we have some very old housing stock
across north east derbyshire which um
is quite troublesome in many ways one of
which is to keep
tenants warm and safe
and we've been very fortunate over the
last 12 months to get
some significant government grants to
insulate these homes and to generally
upgrade them um the first part of that
was in
was in nickley and that is
largely complete and has been very
successful
and now we have received funding which
we will add to
from our own resources to um
to go across the area and and
significantly in improve what we call
these
trad homes and i think that's all i need
to say to be on his chair um
unless cancer kenyan i'm sure will want
to
add about the climate change aspect
of the work that we're doing
thank you council powell i'll hand over
to cancer canyon yes
as council of powell says um we have um
a set of houses that are our council
having
about half our council housing our
extremely inefficient housing was built
after the
second world war on a basically an
urgent basis because we needed housing
um so they're pre-fabricated concrete
blocks single skin
hard to eat and
unfortunately that means expensive to
heat and not only that
they tend to be the poorer residents
that end up living in these so it's sort
of a combination of bad factors
and that we've received is about two
million pounds now
in funding to um address these and the
council's rescheduled
our capital programme to to add to that
funding
um so it's sort of a win-win it reduces
the energy costs significantly it makes
the houses
much nicer to live in and also they
actually look
significantly better because for those
who know the concrete-built houses
they look tatty after a few years as the
best way to describe it
but when they're redone they actually
look decent houses and that has a
an uplift on the whole area wherever we
do this work
um the second part of the report what's
become clear as well though
is that you need to plan for the long
term with this kind of housing
and at the moment the funding streams
they come and they go
um it's good at the moment there's a lot
available but
you really need to be planning on a five
to ten year time scale at least because
we've got
um another two and a half thousand i
think of these in northeast derbyshire
alone
and across derbyshire there's tens of
thousands
and if we're going to achieve the 2050
climate goals what we need
to be doing is creating an environment
where companies
and can invest in the the staffing the
materials the equipment
to apply this sort of external wall
inflation at scale
on well across the country probably many
hundreds of thousands of
houses have come down to usually about
20 different types
so as part of vision derbyshire we've
got an initiative with all the districts
and the county to bring together a
proposal for a sustained funding program
that we will put to government
and hopefully with the support of all
our eight mps in derbyshire as well and
um and get a long-term solution to this
because
it's not getting any better the houses
are
some of the least efficient in the
district in the county and
if we're going to achieve those goals
we've got to have a
serious plan for it and uh i think it's
being well received so far with the um
various i don't know if lee wants to say
anything about
i don't know if there's a meeting this
week baby
uh well i think you've covered it all
just just in terms of how it's been
received everybody's
certainly on board uh and the
opportunity this presents itself
using derbyshire as a footprint and the
level of impact that can have
centralizing effort avoiding duplication
keeps it more efficient but i think
you've covered the point well councillor
kenyon it's about
developing that pipeline so that the
industry clean
cleaner greener economic opportunities
for growth
around that very subject matter this
this proposition allows for that
to develop and i guess that's the crux
of it and the key point
but yeah it's well received so far we've
got a vision derbyshire meeting
on the second of july or fourth of july
maybe where we're hoping
to discuss that paper that is now in
final draft form
uh i think somebody else would need to
move the recommendations
in the report okay thanks uh very much
counselor kenyan
and uh and lee
yeah i am i'd like to move the
recommendation in item one which is that
we note the progress
of the delivery of the incredibly
successful business energy and
industrial strategy
green homes grant to give it its full
title and
also perhaps on behalf of councillor
kenyan to um
move that we accept and item two in the
recommendations that we note
the overview of the proposed derbyshire
wide collaboration
um and to do deliver which will
ultimately deliver large-scale climate
change
and interventions across the whole of
the county i'm
happy to have er to move chair
thank you uh thank you council reading
and camp and just just for me to add
my thanks to cancer kenya and councillor
powell as well of all
as well as all of our officers uh and uh
partners at ricknald
for their uh work together on this
project and
and uh i think it's a well both projects
both the the green homes grand
project has already been outlined is a
fantastic opportunity it really shows
that the district really cares about
investing in our housing
uh and tackling or doing our bit to
tackle climate change at the same time
so it's a really really good scheme
and i fully support and endorse the
the wider derbyshire wide vision
derbyshire project
um and and hope that we can take that
from strength to strength and gather the
support that we need from our mps and uh
and government as well hopefully longer
term so
yeah fully endorsed the paper and very
pleased to see it brought forward so
thank you very much
we'll move to the vote then on that
basis so all those in favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
and then the
next item is the richmond homes
business plan so i'll hand over to
council power again
that's me again um sorry about that
um every year every year written homes
which is our course our
housing partner how to produce their own
business plan it's their business plan
not ours
um and um it's slightly complicated this
year because we were on the brink of
um signing a new management agreement
with ricknald
um which takes into account the recent
government white paper on housing which
gives the council a lot more
responsibilities
so what i'm proposing uh chairman is
that we agree to note the ricknald homes
uh business plan uh from 2021 to 2024
uh but also to agree a six-month review
um of that plan and to um
and that review the purpose of that
review will be to review it in the light
of the new management agreement which as
i say
will be signed very shortly um so that's
my recommendation uh
chair as i say it's it's a written
report it's very it's very full it's
very comprehensive
but it might be subject to change once
the agreement has been
um reached thank you chair
okay thank you council powell i'm happy
to second that are there any comments
from anyone anyone would just make any
comments
i think the only thing i would add is
that the uh i think moving
yeah it's pleasing to see that we we
will be
um reviewing this in light of the new uh
the new management
um management agreement etc i think one
of the key aspects where we need to
see some more detail i think follows on
from the last discussion around climate
change really i think that's one
area where i think all of us as cabinet
would really like to see some more
uh focus and uh and more uh
yeah more detail really i think um so
that's key area and obviously
look forward to seeing it revised in the
future yeah
i i could um i could add uh counselor
dale
that um counselor kenyan and myself had
a meeting with rick norden yesterday
specifically about climate change
aspects of
the plan and moving forward so uh
progress is already being made sure okay
that's good
um okay thank you very much um so unless
there's any other further comments
i'm happy to move to the vote all those
in favor
okay that's carried uh and
people who turn the microphone
microphone off um
then we move to urgent items uh of which
uh there are none and then the exclusion
of the pr
of the public so thank you very much for
uh joining us if you have done today
and we look forward to seeing you soon
so on that basis i move that the public
be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in part one of schedule 12a
to the local government act
1972. i think that's it thank you very
much
you